hey folks Peter Brown here at comic-con
2014 and in tendo's gaming lounge things
are exciting they're loud colors
everywhere I'm here my friend Daniel
probably marketing manager at Nintendo
I'm behind us is Bayonetta 2 from
Platinum Games
well actually we are showing beta 2 and
even this is the new anime that's giving
it's coming out as well offer bayonet
that's being made by the FO samurai just
say there so yeah the enemy is coming
out as well we are showing up beta 2
with you are playing right over here
yeah which is over there yes way my life
and here were having a chance to play
through the different chapters that are
in the game to get an understanding of
how powerful Bayonetta is and how she's
able to fight along and it's just a
crazy over-the-top action and using all
of her special powers she has to go
through the game like right now here the
McMahan go hear about the game as always
about making those combos happen and
even dodging at the right time if you
notice when you dodged at the right time
the screen goes purple which is
essentially which time and everything
slows down from where you can actually
start executing even more powerful
combos you're going through that like
right there
so Planum games is known for making
they're sort of like over the top you
know action games with like really great
visuals and then I gotta say this is
probably one of the best visually
looking Wii U games that I've seen
they've really managed to tap into that
are they I mean does this keep up the
whole time is this whole game like this
bombastic yet a game is this crazy
over-the-top action in all times and
what's really cool about the game people
who are fans that they in a series beta
1 is known mainly for the fact that
you're fighting against the angels and
and this one was changed a bit more now
is that your friend Jean her soul has
been stolen at the same time demons have
now turned against at the same time so
now beignet is having to fight not just
the angels but also the demons as she
goes into purgatory breaks like
purgatory ax to attempt to help rescue
John and from there the story will
continue to evolve from that point as
well also the game there is a
multiplayer aspect Felicia we haven't
really given a lot of detail yet but
there will be a way to play multiplayer
online called tag climax we'll have more
information about that coming soon as
well and only imagine what that's gonna
be like you mentioned the first
Bayonetta as I understand that's
included with Bayonetta 2 correct
correct Bayonetta when you if you buy
beta 2 it'll come with two disks mana to
which the game you're seeing here and
will also come with Bayonetta 1 as well
and what's cool about being a 1 it's not
just the original game they did work out
on
working on a little bit to improve it a
bit but the big improving they add is
that you can now use Nintendo costs at
the same time so you guys see dress up
you actually have costs that you unlock
that you can be Samus you can be
Princess Peach and like that and what's
cool though it even changes how the game
plays a bit so when you're playing
Princess Peach
instead of getting halos when you defeat
enemies halos pop out kind of currency
and when you're playing with Princess
Peach in Bayonetta one you'll actually
get coins and I'll you make the coins
sound that people are used to hearing
from Nintendo and then also instead of
when attacking with her special powers
in with Bayonetta like you should right
there her feet stuck these feet stomp
out what's going on if you're playing
with Princess Peach it'll be Bowser's
foot popping out or his fists punching
out they did some nice little fandom
calls to the Nintendo series to add some
nice touches to the game for Bayonetta 1
alright if you did pick one Nintendo
character to play as in the Bayonetta
game which would you choose
I'm a big fan of Samus Samus is always
my favorite character yeah it's serious
so that's gonna be a fun one to use as
well but here in beta G I mean right
here just as you've been watching this
whole time in talking my beta 1 a bit to
it has been just over the top crazy
action using different kinds of powers
this thing coming up there was even
great - if you're fighting smaller
enemies you give me you something called
torture attacks where if you pull of a
special move you be able to like
basically push the enemy into like a
giant guillotine or kind of grinders and
all this kind of crazy supposed to be
happening on the screen at the same time
all right well that's a pretty good look
at Bayonetta 2
GameSpot is going to be all over Comic
Con 2014 for the next couple days so
stay tuned